Scoob do you realize where we are no
look here man the clean modernist thing
the cool-blue color palette
we're in Mikey oh did you say IKEA nope
I said well can't you just like you
Shaggy and Scooby were taken yeah this
blue light came down from the sky and
beamed them up thank you breathe I have
to assume that if they were with their
friends they wouldn't have been
kidnapped
okay can you skip the emotional
punishment what was some guy who almost
Scooby and Shaggy I don't know but I'd
like to shake the hand of whoever
created this and then you know throw
that hand in prison for trying to kill
our friends
[Applause]
this mangy stray is coming with me he's
not a stray okay then what's his name
his name's Scooby middle name doobie
last name do gentlemen welcome aboard
this isn't about some guy in a rubber
mask I would have gotten away with this
and forward for you meddling this is
about one of us
welcome to the Falcon hang on turn on
the lights
where are my balloons didi when I say
Falcon fury that's supposed to cue the
balloons oh great great timing you might
want to buckle up
[Music]
weirdo beardo maybe this can lead us to
our culprit jinkies apparently he's been
stealing Netflix by using his mother's
account that is not fair for the rest of
us who have to pay for Netflix you have
to pay for Netflix
if you want you can pull over a compass
up here I guess our new movie is an
origin story that we hero should have
won I want the rock to play me
[Music]
you